on n'a même pas été fichus de mettre en
mettre au point en france en tout cas
une application de traçage de nos
données téléphoniques par exemple en
tout cas qu'ils soient alors c'est une
réponde pas d'intelligence artificielle
on a l'impression que la haine et cela
est capable de nous localiser nous
filmer n'importe où en réalité on en est
très très loin de ce qu'on imaginait en
termes de surveillance et le contrôle de
masse sans doute mais le traçage si vous
ne savez pas qui est malade à quoi ils
vous c'est là or pour savoir qui est
malade il faut des tests qu'il faut
avoir progressé et ce virus comme je les
vis était parfaitement inédit donc le
confinement c'est la réponse en effet
traditionnel mais qui a fait ses preuves
et pour cause d'ailleurs philippe escola
anthropologue au collège je pense que
j'entendais l'autre jour disait que les
indiens d'amazonie
quand et d'épidémies ils se disent
personnes c'est un peu ce contrat du
confinement ils se dispersent dans la
forêt pour éviter les contacts
donc c'est quelque chose d'assez
classique mais qui a fait preuve de son
efficacité
et c'est pas pour vous démentir mais
mais je trouve en tant qu'observateur
que la vitesse avec laquelle la
recherche mondiale s'est mise en action
sur ce coronavirus aussi bien pour
trouver des traitements que pour
inventer des tests que pour
éventuellement proposer un vaccin pour
la suite
c'est assez vertigineux la vitesse à
laquelle il donnait se sont échangées
est hélas que le rythme auquel des
publications sont fait que d'ailleurs
personne n'a le temps d'assimiler
tellement saoul nombreuses c'est à dire
que la recherche est vraiment très
active et quand on arrive quand même à
répondre à certaines questions de façon
assez rapide sur les motos contagion sur
le profil de ceux qui tombent malades
sur les porteurs sains sur cette
question de l'immunité que donnerait le
fait d'avoir été mis en contact avec le
virus
lorsqu'on aura quand même la réponse un
jour et est ce les chercheurs qui l'a de
londres donc si je trouve que le bus
tata par exemple a permis d'aller très
vite dans certains domaines de recherche
et on a on a progressé scientifiquement
[Musique]